i mean to me i twitch uh like irl
streamers is just built different i
don't know
like i don't know how they do i think
you have to be an another level of like
masochist
yeah i think i i to me it seems like why
would you want to be embarrassed in
public yeah
yeah like constantly yeah i don't mind
doing it for a video every now and then
yeah but like
having it constantly on because at least
in a video when you're out there filming
when you're out and about there filming
at least you can like edit it so it's
the most interesting things that
happened on the day but
if it's an irl stream you see everything
and i'm just
and it's just especially when you're not
even even in the safety of your own home
either you're out there in public people
can see you people can judge you
and to me that's just a level of like
that's that's the dystopian future that
i i don't want in my life i don't know
yeah i've gone wrong yeah i was saying
like not to mention like
in japan especially where people are
already [ __ ]
way too wary about filming in public
yeah right yeah
i i don't know how you can just like
rock up to an izakaya full of people
and just be like yeah i'm just gonna put
this camera here and just start talking
yeah
i i i i don't know i don't i couldn't do
that either i don't know i haven't tried
it but like
i i don't know how would i i would get
over that mental barrier
of just going going to around
restaurants like having the phone in
front of me and just talking to the
phone now i'm too british i can't do
that
yeah the thought of going into just a
place and doing that is like what like
just like on the street as well like
i don't get how like like j vloggers for
instance can like just be walking on the
streets by themselves
just have a camera like this and being
late all right guys so we're going to go
to blah blah blah and just
have people staring at you i've done
that it looks like a [ __ ] hostage
video i'm like [ __ ] talking down to
the camera like
yeah like i i i wouldn't like
i don't know i mean to me it's like you
know and i watch some of these irl
streams
i'm quite interested in myself and i
think yeah like oh maybe i could do it
sometime but then
you know when i watch it i'm like okay
cool they did like one cool thing in the
day
and the rest of it like a lot of the
time they were just being like sitting
there asking their chat like what do you
guys want to do you just want to do what
should we do guys and it's like all
right
and then everybody get what the appeal
was because most of the time real life's
pretty [ __ ] boring you're just
like traveling or waiting yeah exactly i
think
in this day and age i feel it's a type
of content that is like really small
yeah maybe right now i can understand
that but before that i'm like why would
you want to watch someone just kind of
like wait
and sit around all day and maybe do
something interesting for one hour
because
it's like you're really there i i get it
in covert times isn't this some kind of
like black mirror-esque [ __ ] that we're
getting
though like i just want i don't want to
have a day myself i'm going to watch
someone else have a day
and i'm going to give them money it's
like it's literally that [ __ ]
image of you know that kid sitting in
front of like the the poster
being like every podcast be like
that just keeps getting posted on us
yeah
because like for me like i i feel
awkward if i have a hands-free set
and i'm just in public and i'm on the
phone yeah like
sometimes i have a hands-free set and i
have the phone up to my face
to look like i'm talking on the phone
yeah to exactly supposed to
talking to myself i don't know yeah
because the other day uh
i had to go buy like some uh some like
eyelashes for rocky
so i went to like the local was it this
one yeah no yeah the local pharmacy and
i was like
[ __ ] i don't know which one she wants so
so i tried to like
you know take some pictures and send her
being like yeah pick out which one it is
and she just [ __ ] calls me and it's
like just show me
so i had to like flip the camera and i'm
just i'm just doing this while talking
on a hands-free set and these old women
are looking at me like what the [ __ ] is
this guy doing
it's like they probably understand
filming eyelashes and being like which
one
i don't know why i find like only irl
content is where it feels a little black
mirrory to me a little weird i don't
know why
like no no other type of content makes
me feel in that weird kind of
this is like no other content makes me
feel like this is too far like
irl just some something about it
sometimes i'm watching it i'm like
well because like i feel that like if
you stream in like say a studio like
this right
there's like a performative side to it
it's almost like a stage or like a setup
like like there is literal sets
that we perform in like yes yeah but
sitting down for like three hours at an
izakaya while like having a casual beer
it's a little too realistic as well like
i saw a lot of them like a lot of them
get like
drunk a lot of the time and that's like
the audience loves that oh yeah i love
it when they get drunk because they're
like oh they could [ __ ] up they could
yeah
stuff like so the audience constantly
eggs them into drinking yeah people are
like waiting for the next like stream
and i'm like i'm like [ __ ] is that
that's a horrible relationship to have
your viewers where they just want to see
you [ __ ]
[ __ ] everything that's probably yeah i
mean i i feel like even though
even though you're it's an irl stream
you know when we're streaming we do have
this performative side to us that we
just talked about
um that we feel like we want to be we
want something interesting to happen or
we
at least want an interesting
conversation to happen so i feel like
it's a very i i don't know like
unhealthy kind of
like relationship to have with your
viewers at that point because
your your best interest is for something
to happen so you are in this
performative side and i've talked to a
few irl streamers who
have done things on their streams which
they probably wouldn't have done if
you know nobody was watching right yeah
you definitely get that like fake
confidence yeah yeah stream watching you
i mean isn't that where like the whole
generalization of like
you know fan bases of ireland streamers
being like
they're pretty [ __ ] toxic yeah like i
i know a couple of viral streamers in
japan as well and
you know they're all lovely people yeah
you know off stream yeah
but i think it's because of the fact
that they have this really
toxic and you know quite aggressive type
of audience that loves to egg them on to
make them do stupid [ __ ] or you know
fail in some way that they kind of get
dragged into that and yeah you know hate
to say it a lot of them
on stream turn into a bit of an [ __ ]
but that's also because you know
you have thousands sometimes tens of
thousands of people being like
yeah do this thing that makes you look
like an [ __ ] for our entertainment
yeah
it's kind of unfortunate because it's
like a you know if you're being an
[ __ ]
you know but your audience is enjoying
it and the ecking you on you could you
can almost get lost in the fact that
no i don't think i'm being an [ __ ] i
think i'm being entertaining right right
right i think so but then you know you
see them when you talk to them one on
one you realize oh
they're actually quite normal nothing
like they are nothing like this
they're really nice most of the time i
don't know maybe i'm over generalizing i
don't know
i haven't met many but the ones i have
met are very different to how they act
on stream
yeah yeah i mean yeah i only really know
like a few who are like exactly the same
but
that's i feel it's a rare breed yeah